abonne toi mais la cloche
[Musique]
regardez ce qu'on a reçu logitech brio
4k stream caméra on en reparlera d'ici
quelques jours et on a aussi reçu deux
philips c'est j'ai mangé le non scellées
philips play like barre cool
aujourd'hui je vous parle de shadow
l'entreprise blade alors qu'il ya
quelques jours à paris c'était shadow
world the shadow war c'était qui note
grande kinnock sur plusieurs jours
franchement je crois je dis pas trop
endettés j'étais à la keynote de
lancement de shadow world événements
enormissime plein de belles rencontres
plein donc intéressante
et justement je dois vous dire nous
[Musique]
là on est à la soirée shadow shadow vous
connaissez c'est le pc dans le cloud
société française s'appelle bled on les
a rencontrés à vegas il quelques bon moi
j'ai fait un sujet dessus c'est juste
coup physiquement fait parce que c'est
une entreprise qui se développe à
vitesse grand v
et là il ya des nouveautés il ya des
annonces qui sont fait valoir tout hyper
cool donc là on est à paris pour un
event franchement atypique et croyez-moi
ça le pc dans le cloud c'est un truc qui
va énormément se développer cette
entreprise française elle est juste au
top par rapport à ça jean même visité
moi ta ta ta ta ta ta avant toute chose
est ce que vous connaissez shadow est ce
que vous savez réellement ce que c'est
je pense que faire une mise au point
avant toute chose je vais vous ramener
aux 6es en janvier 2018 et qui elle dit
ce qui va vous expliquer un peu
rapidement ce qu'est shadow
c'est simplement le premier pc haut de
gamme qui est entièrement accessible par
le cloud
le principe c'est que au lieu d'avoir
tous les trucs qui font qu'on a
habituellement dans une grosse bourde
sur son bureau qui chauffe qui ont la
place pour sauver normand l'électricité
nous on a décidé de mettre tous ses
composants dans un datacenter et d'y
accéder par une simple connexion
internet à partir de 15 du capital
bon maintenant que vous savez réellement
ce qu'est shadow on va pouvoir continuer
je vous ramène avec moi à shadow wars
vous allez voir qu'on est assez thousand
affecté que ça c'est énorme
j'ai toujours rêvé on fait de faire
monter sur la musique de bowden merci
beaucoup merci
emmanuel tenter le studio de shadow tu
peux me présenter à votre nouveau projet
que je comprenne bien en fait aïe le but
c'est justement de laisser aux et
meurent est créé
on a une commune
de 50000 personnes 16 52 personnes c'est
énorme et ensuite y en a vingt minutes
sans réussir douze derniers mois
ces cinquante mille personnes qui jouent
ensemble qui utilisent des ordinateurs
qui sont en fait juste à côté les uns
et le but c'est de dire
bon là
maintenant quand on maîtrise la
technologie de pouvoir vers d'utiliser
un écran plus grand
pouvoir commencer à jouer ensemble à se
partager le rythme de partager les coûts
troll ajoutée et faire faire des
variants sur le jeu des modifications
des changements qui vont faire comme eux
mêmes ou pour créer leurs propres jeux
quelle manière ils peuvent le faire ça
alors d'abord en ailleurs la vignette de
gens de la vignette qu'avec avec l'écran
des gens avec qui j ai encore jouer avec
un ami belge à avoir mon écran en plein
du genre un petit ligne est qui a montré
l'écran de mon ami juste à côté d'eux
est de souligner est potentiellement je
vous la grandir je peux la rétrécir que
je peux mozilla met your man d'écran et
voir l'écran mon ami
donc ça va permettre par exemple moi pas
répondre de regarder les séries avec ma
copine et et le faire ensemble sur la
même série sur l'intrus quand même
concédé par att ça va permettre à des
joueurs qui jouent ensemble sur des
réseaux des trucs de pouvoir voir à tout
le monde ce qu'ils sont en train vers où
est ce qu'ils sont une forme unique et
non plus avec le casting
mais cette fois aussi avec l'image ok
donc ça c'est la première étape la
deuxième étape c'est à dire que en plus
de donner les contrôles et les écrans
voir porter d'autres choses on va
pouvoir rajouter un servant des faits au
jeu
des faits qui vont
hé bé extrêmement complexes par exemple
mais maître de la pluie sur le jeu où
tous ont été courts et donc
voir comment c'est une course de
voitures et avec des couettes ou les on
est quatre jeux à faire une course
mario car même si ça ne va pas au jeu m
contre les toutes les minutes
un effet qui va durer de 10 secondes 2
toujours conduire entre quand quand
l'écran va si un peu comme si j'étais
bourré moi j'aimais ça a duré dix
secondes
donc c'est juste marrant mais ça
pourrait aussi les choses un peu plus à
beaucoup de technique ça va rendre les
joueurs plus difficile par exemple sur
un jeu comme quand night g pouvoir
ajouter des effets revue paris d'en
faire un autre joueur je suis envoyé un
malus pour qu'ils aient plus de
difficultés à viser pour cette reprise
embêtant les cf voilà donc on prend les
unissait de plein de façons différentes
et quelque part c'est mon joueur
on va fournir une vingtaine de pays au
départ qui vont s'agrémenter au fur à
mesure pour en avoir une centaine
mais chaque joueur va pouvoir même
inventé son propre effet et l'appliquer
soit d'une façon globale soit simplement
d'un bel ou bonus malus lauriers roses
[Applaudissements]
à
bon là on n'avait que jérôme de la
chaîne now t'es con soir à tous comment
ces gérants à vous présenter pour toi tu
utilises château oui je dis très belle
je suis un early bird donc géré un suivi
shadow quand il était tout petit il
n'existait quasiment pas moi je fais
partie des 100 premiers reprendre un
château c'est normal aujourd'hui ton
retour sans shadow c'est quoi bah écoute
leur tour moi je fais partie des gens
j'ai pas de problème j'ai eu des
problèmes mais j'en ai très peu d'accord
j'en ai globalement autant qu'avec un pc
classique auquel va dire un pc classique
parfois ça tombe en panne et où après je
l'utilisé vraiment con l'instant
uniquement pour jouer
j'installe rien de fantaisiste dessus en
driver machin moi je fais pas d
expérience dessus j'allume je fais mes
parties dover watch et voilà donc
globalement cet usage là sans notre avis
du produit la purge des vidéos c'est
beaucoup plus que ça
c'est de laisser et les secteurs le
savent eux mêmes aussi un c'est de
laisser aux joueurs
le fait de créer eux mêmes quelques
brins leur parti au dessus des jeux
proposés par l'éditeur indique terriens
groll bon compte ont en général n'en
parle pas des jeux en
classé mais un lecteur et un rôle non
content quand sur mon jeu comme ans qui
campe d'avoir des modes qui sont créées
dessus celle des joueurs ont commencé à
faire des variations de jeu et les
publier avec la communauté va commencer
à se repérer et c'est ça qui va
commencer à se passer on sait d'ailleurs
il ya plein de jeux qui sont nées d'un
type de jeu les battle royale les mauves
à essence et noir sont
à cause de variation d'un jeu de départ
où les joueurs ont fait leur camp comme
mode pour trouver d'autres façons de
jouer dessus
donc c'est ça effectivement pour retirer
ces données ou aux joueurs là besoin de
créer des sur jeu de mots
existants exactement comme ils le
veulent qu'est ce que tu penses de
nouvelles annonces ayvaz écoute avoir je
moi moi je suis pas coeur de cible ça
peut être fun pour des gens qui jouent
souvent ensemble ce que j'étais sensible
cette histoire de retrouver l'atmosphère
des lames
mais on a connu les lan physique où on
se découd entre amis
on essaye de travailler les jeux on
essaie d'augmenter la difficulté ça peut
être fun j'ai fait un coeur de cible
mais ça peut être notre but c'est
justement là nous passons pourra ouvrir
le jeu vidéo
l'axé aujourd'hui nous pouvons aussi à
tout en fait d'abord le club sait il y
avait déjà deux catégories de gens il y
avait les riches et les pauvres
il y avait en ça c'est un peu un
débordement de la ville de la campagne
il ya les riches pouvaient s p s'est
payé un super ordinateur ou une superbe
console et d'en avoir plusieurs
excellents d'avoir tous les jeux et le
port qui avaient pas les moyens de
s'acheter un ordinateur ne pouvait pas
jouer on consomme et effectivement les
derniers jours qu'ils sortaient qui
avait pas la configuration nécessaire et
que jouer avec sans frais ni de loin aux
vins près de nous autres prennent deux
mois qu'un
autre qu'un autre jour à côté de ça le
club est en train de casser ça donc sur
des connexions effectivement
l'équivalent sur un endroit où il ya
plus problème de
financiers qui vont interdire l'accès
alors effectivement comme tu dis il ya
encore des preuves sur la connexion
dans ce rayon clair un mec qui à la
campagne ça sent qu'un pic de deux ans
mais quand il joue avec plus de jambes
quand ils jouent au foot nike a toujours
des problèmes
c'est mal c'est pas hyper phase i de son
expérience de jeu est quand même il ya
toujours il ya déjà un phénomène joueurs
en vie les jours à la campagne jours
avec des bonnes connexions et jouer que
ça existe déjà
dans sa marche déjà avec se payer du
second
comme j'ai dit pendant
pour ce il ya des joueurs pleins de
joueurs qui ont des connexions à 10 15
mai des missions qui ont recommencé à ce
prix mais alors que normalement ils sont
là compagne alors que sont des
corrections mauvaise nos propres château
pour bénéficier d'une connexion un
gigabit pour pouvoir commencer à faire
des choses qu'on va faire avec leur
connexion tu as d'avoir un ping
extrêmement bas le support construit
vais télécharger les jeux très rapide au
pouvoir jouer aux offres de steam le
week-end plein de choses comme ça
notre but ça va être toujours d'adapter
la connexion ou pas possible voire même
là dessus de tabor des ordinateurs
c'est même sans internet
c'est un peu le lait en très gros tu
peux imaginer des spots dit vas y
tu as accès internet accès à toute la
musique du monde
on va t'appeler l'accès internet le
sélectionneur ça tombe de chose que tu
peux avoir un local pour imaginer que
dans l'autre c'est pareil on a un accès
à internet mais mauvais au moyen qui va
accéder à une puissance phénoménale et
avec toutes les applications montrent le
jeu
quant à + internet tu continueras à voir
des vaches au 4e tour 04 qui vont
pouvoir faire tourner la tête
aura toujours des consoles classiques
droite aux ordinateurs classiques qui
mettent d'accord
à près de s'arrêter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour shadow world pour l'univers
shadow alors vous avez compris shadow
c'est un pc gaming dans le cloud
mais c'est surtout une vision de
l'avenir sur ce que va être l'ordinateur
l'ordinateur en règle générale
ordinateur dans le cloud je sais pas si
c'est un truc qui peut vous intéressez
vous qui vous parle
est ce que vous pourriez être tenté à
vous dire voilà je laisse mon ordinateur
dans le crunch puisqu'il faut vraiment
réfléchir et ce qui est très intéressant
que vous avez juste vous besoin d'une
connexion adsl pour vous connecter à
votre honneur de claude et de là vous
pouvez télécharger à des vitesses
incroyables en fibres parce que l'odeur
datacenter ils ont des connexions qui
vont y perd vite donc en gros vous
téléchargez en fibres en ayant des dsl
vous le suivez le truc assez énorme donc
c'est super super super intéressant je
vous invite à me dire ce que vous en
pensez en banc commentaire est ce que
vous avez déjà cette solution est ce que
vous l'avez c est ce que ça pourrait
vous intéresser
et est ce que vous pensez au final que
les connexions internet sont assez bien
desservi je pense en france mais aussi
dans d'autres pays du monde je sais que
vous êtes nombreux à me suivre dans le
monde entier ont dites moi ce que vous
en pensez vous pour votre pays si vous
êtes en france vous marquez tout ça en
commentaire quant à moi vous en rendez
vous très bientôt
soyez sages on va reparler de cloud
gaming va parler d'ordinateurs dans le
code on va paraître plein de trucs et
vous avez vu qu'il ya des nouveaux
produits sont arrivés donc c'est hyper
cool d'ici là soyez sages
je vous embrasse et à bientôt au chat